Hello, my name is Charles Che and welcome to my talk, reimagining the EMAX user experience
with Casual Suite. Casual Suite is a set of opinionated user interfaces to different
modes offered in EMAX. But before I get into describing Casual in detail, let's first
talk about the existing EMAX user experience. To make EMAX go, people can either invoke
commands by name with execute extended command, run a command directly with a pre-assigned
keybinding, finally use a mouse menu if it's available. From human computer interface
research, there is a concept of recall versus recognition in user interface design. Let's
show their distinction by example. A common recall interface is password entry. Absent
any historical affordances, a user must directly remember information to succeed with this
interface. In contrast, menus offer immediate visual cues on what commands are available.
This allows a user to recognize familiar behavior to support successful selection of
it. From user interface research, the key finding is this. Interfaces emphasizing recognition
are much easier to use than those relying on recall. In this light, we see that the EMAX
user experience leans too much towards recall. Completion in history can help tip the scales
towards recognition, but only by a little bit. This reliance on recall is discouraging to
users both new and old, and that's a shame because EMAX has so many useful commands. But
the kicker is that most of them are infrequently used. You can't recall them all, at least
I can't. So, a conundrum. While I've been using EMAX since the early 90s, truthfully, it's
been only in this past decade that I've leveled up in using it. Word mode, magit, eglot,
avi, and many other packages have transformed how I use it. I can only deal with so much cognitive
load and physically straining key bindings. So, what to do about it? Let's bring back an
old ideal. Keyboard-driven menus have been around since TTY video terminals would mainframes.
If you're old enough to recall working with such interfaces, these terms will seem familiar.
They all worked with the limitations of text-based video displays. With keyboard-driven menus,
if a command exists, but nobody can find it, it's not really useful. A well-designed menu
can make a command discoverable. If the command is infrequently used, making it recognizable
helps a lot. And for working primarily with text, having keyboard-only interactions
encourages flow. Given the above, the next step seemed natural.
Augment EMAX with keyboard-driven menus. This is not saying that I want to obsolete name
commands, key bindings, and mouse menus. They all can happily coexist. EMAX is large. It
can contain multitudes. Conveniently, EMAX has a built-in library for building such menus.
It's called Transient, and it's been around since EMAX 28. Developed primarily by Jonas
Bernoulli as a UI toolkit for McGit, Transient has an essential feature for building great
keyboard-driven interfaces. A transit menu can be pinned, and their state updated as commands
are issued from them. This lets us build interfaces that reflect internal state changes made by
commands issued from the user. This is great because many modes have stable behavior and
guess what? EMAX has a lot of modes. If you think about it, EMAX modes are akin to the
ecosystem of apps that we see today, but would far less structure and packaging. A mode,
like an app, focuses on delivering specific behavior to the user. There are many built-in modes
in EMAX, and these modes are complex with dozens, if not hundreds, of commands. Calc itself
has over a thousand of them. It's frustrating to know that these commands are there, but
I really can't access them via recall, so I decided to do something about it. And that
was to transient all the modes, or at least the most major ones. This past summer, I had
the time and resources to start building transit interfaces for modes that I wanted to more
elegantly use. I decided to call this work casual. Given its definition, it seemed like
a good fit for a vibe that I wanted these interfaces to embody. Design principles that I embraced
up front were handcrafted information architecture and layout. This is largely an exercise in mapping
a modes command set to a hierarchical menu structure. I wanted these menus to make sense
to most people. Ideally, users would not have to read documentation to get at the command
that they wanted. Early on, I quickly learned that it was impossible to maintain the existing
default key bindings when mapping them over to a hierarchical menu. Also, some bindings
I just flat out disagreed with. So I resolved to be friendly, but not beholden to them.
In all of the above, I've gone out of my way to make clear that my design decisions are
opinionated. Using casual. To reinforce habit, a common key binding is used
per mode to raise a main menu. This key binding is left to user preference. For me, that binding
is control O. Command bindings are anonomic when possible.
What specific sightings are given their own menu? Since transient menus can be pinned,
we can support repeat or stateful behavior in a mode. As of this writing, there are eleven
modes supported by casual with several more on the way. Let's look at the casual menu for
Dured to highlight the design conventions previously mentioned. In a Dured EMAX window, the user
can invoke their preferred key binding to call a top-level casual main menu. This main
menu is displayed at the bottom of the EMAX frame.
Zooming into this menu, we see the commands offered in it categorized into different sections.
Each command has a key binding, usually a single character shown before its label. The
file section holds commands that act upon the currently selected item or marked items.
The directory section holds commands that affect the current directory or its subdures
within it. The Mark section has marking commands that allow for aggregate operations.
The navigation section shows commands that move the point in a Dured buffer.
The Quick section provides access to bookmark and buffer list commands. Searching Replace
commands are grouped in the search section. New directory and file creation are given
their own section. Finally, at the bottom of the menu are commands dedicated to casual
menu navigation.
Casuals conform to transient conventions where the key binding control G for dismiss one
and control Q to dismiss all menus are honored. Another transient convention is to reserve
the key binding Q to quit the current mode. For most main menus, casual uses the comma
key binding to invoke a mode specific settings menu. Casual also adopts the common UI convention
of using ellipsis and greater than symbols to denote required input and sub menus respectively.
Some commands are more global or non-mode specific in nature. A great deal of these commands
relate to editing, which I find to be a prime motivation for using EMAX. Let's examine
one such menu that supports this.
The main menu for casual edit kit is designed to provide easy access to editing and editing
related commands. Like the previous Dured menu, it organizes commands into different sections.
Commands related to file and buffer operations are in the file section. Commands for editing
text are in the edit section. S or balanced expression commands are given a dedicated section
for their own. More often than not, in many modes, I find them to do what I want.
The tool section provides access to common tools. Bookmarks, I consider it to be an essential
feature. If you haven't used them, it's never too late to start.
EMAX window management commands are given a section. Commands for search and replace,
macros, and projects can be accessed from here.
Finally, the menu navigation section. Note that register commands can be accessed from here.
Okay, enough screenshots. Let's look at casual inaction with a demo of the edit kit menus.
So let's start our demo of casual edit kit with raising the menu, which is bound to Control
O. You'll see the menu pop up here. And in particular, we want to look at the edit
operation. So we'll press E. And we'll see a number of menu items that allow you to make
editing transformations to the text. Be it marking, copying, killing, transposing, transforming,
moving, or deleting the text. You'll see also that there is a sub menu for rectangle operations.
And let's first, let's actually dig through and look at what's in the mark sub menu.
And you'll see that there increments of text in which you can mark, you can mark a word,
a sentence, a paragraph, and balance expression. If we go back, you'll see a similar pattern
for copying, as well as killing and transposing. Let's go and try to move a sentence. We have
the point there at hello there. And we'll move that sentence around. If we press S, we can
move it backward or forward. In this case, let's move it forward. So we'll press F. And you'll
see hello there. Move up a sentence. And then we can also press B to move it back. And then
press return to dismiss. Also, if we wanted to, we can, in this menu, particularly, you'll
see that we also have cursor navigation, so we can move the point there. That's not in
all the menus, but in a good part number of the menus in casual edit kit, you'll see that
here. Let's press return to dismiss that. And let's actually look at some rectangle operations
here. In this case, we have a list with items x, y, and z. And let's say we wanted to prefix
each item here with a string. And we'll say let's, we want to put in there. Hello. So one
way of doing that is to make a rectangle. And so if we go into our rectangle menu, first
off, what we need to do is define that rectangle region. So we'll press M to mark where the
point is right there. And then we can use our cursor operation to move the point to define
the rectangle. In this case, it's right at the start there. We can use the string insert
command i to insert hello, colon, and then we'll put a space there to make it look a little
nicer. And sure enough, that's in there. And we've, we can have access to a number of rectangle
commands here. So if we wanted to, let's say, number, we can go through that same operation
here, define a region, a rectangle region that is, and press N. And you'll see that it has
incremented a number for each item in that rectangle region. We can also press U, tap
U to undo these operations and leave that at that sorting. If we select a region here,
and we go back, you'll see that the sort sub menu is now enabled. Sorting won't work unless
you have a region started. So that's one of the nice things about transient is that it
allows you to visually just enable or disable command items with regards to whatever the
current state or context is here. And in this case, is whether or not you have a region
highlighted. And let's say we want to sort these two columns of numbers. And so there's
a command called N here, which is numeric fields. And let's choose that here. And sure enough,
we get that. But there's a nice twist there. If, well, let's say we wanted to sort on the
second column. So let's move our point back up to here. And we'll mark that. And since everything
is in a continuous line, we can sort of pretend that this region is actually a paragraph and mark that.
And we'll go and select our sort routine. But now we need to figure out how to make numeric fields
sort on the second column. So in transient, if we press a question mark, that gives us basically
a intermediate help section where if we press a key binding, it will tell us or
load the doc string for the command that's there. And so that command in this case is sort of numeric
fields. And it is requires an argument. And that argument can be passed using the prefix argument
control you. So press Q. And let's do that. In this case, we want to check or use the value 2. And press
N. And sure enough, that region is sorted with respect to the second column.
Before casual, so many powerful EMAX commands were not available to me because there were two
hard to recall or I could not discover them. Making casual has changed that, letting me reimagine
more positively my user experience with EMAX. If you're interested in any of what I've shown today,
I invite you to try out casual. Before I leave, my thanks and acknowledgements go out to the following
people. First, to Jonas Bernoulli for making transient and McGit, casual would not be possible without
your work. Next to psionic k for writing transient showcase, it showed me how I could build casual.
To all the casual users and their support, I am genuinely appreciative.
And finally to John Snater for writing the kind post on casual on the IREAL website. Thank you.
Casual can be found on Melpa and its repository is hosted on GitHub.
[BLANK_AUDIO]